Okay, good morning. So, today this
morning we are doing the Renaissance.
Specifically, we are asking the question
how the Renaissance. How did the
Renaissance start?
Because the Renaissance was a revolution
was an intellectual revolution
in
Europe that would ultimately change the
fate of Europe. Okay, guys?
The Renaissance was a reimagining of
classical Greece in a Christian European
context. Okay? So, what the Renaissance
is going to do is combine
classical Greece with Christian Europe
and it's going to create modernity.
All right, so the ideas
the values that underpin modernity, the
world we live in today, starts with the
Renaissance.
Okay, so the question we are looking at
this morning is how did the Renaissance
start?
Okay, and there are lots of very
different theories. And what scholars
today believe is it was a perfect storm
of cultural, historical, economic
trends. Okay, so let's look at the main
factors. The first is
the decline of Constantinople. So, for
hundreds of years, Constantinople was
the epicenter of European culture. It is
the heir to the Roman Greco-Roman
legacy. But as the Ottoman Turks start
to encroach on Byzantine territory,
a lot of the scholars, a lot of the
major thinkers of Byzantine Empire, they
start to shift back to Europe. And they
bring with them Plato, Aristotle. Okay?
So, that's one major factor. The
Crusades. The Crusades, remember we
discussed last class, it was a time when
Europeans encountered the Muslim world
at mass and as result they absorb a lot
of the culture and politics of the
Islamic golden age.
Then there was a fact that in Italy you
had many different city-states in
competition with each other. And we as
we discussed in many classes before,
when you have that you have something
called open cooperative competition
which leads to
innovation, okay? Also, what's really
important for us to remember is that
because these city-states were always at
war with each other, everyone was a
participant in history.
Remember if you are a if you are in an
imperial bureaucracy, if you're a
bureaucrat, you can sort of stand
outside of history and observe history.
But if you're a participant in history,
then you are fighting wars. You're a
participant in politics.
Okay? You're always thinking about the
relevance of your theory to reality.
Um the three major city-states of
Italy that will give rise to Renaissance
are Florence, Venice, and
Genoa. Venice and Genoa are known for
their slave trade. Okay? So they're
trading slaves with the Muslim world and
through this trade they're bringing back
uh the books, the ideas, the values of
the Islamic world into Europe. As well,
because of the trade and commerce,
um these three city-states become
extremely wealthy and that allows them
to patronize the arts.
Um so you have the rise of a merchant
elite in Florence. The family is called
the Med-
Medicis, okay? Why this is important is
um previous elites were either of the
warrior class or the priest class.
If you're a warrior class, you win your
legitimacy by
fighting the battlefield. If you're a
priest, your legitimacy comes from God
or the gods.
But if you're a merchant elite, the
question then is where does your
legitimacy come from? And so because of
this question, the Medicis are forced to
patronize a lot of the arts. They will
patronize individuals including
Da Vinci,
Raphael, Michelangelo, basically the
major artists
of the Renaissance.
Okay?
Um
at this time from 1305 to 1378, there
are actually two Popes in Europe.
There's a crisis of legitimacy and
authority in the Catholic Church. The
Pope moves to Avignon and therefore the
Pope doesn't really have authority over
Italy.
You also have
the rise of universities and
monasteries. Universities and
monasteries are places of theological
debate and discussion. And they store
the classics and this is where a lot of
new ideas will come from. And then
the last factor to think about is in
1440, around then,
a man named Gutenberg, he will invent
the printing press. And the printing
press allows for the rapid dissemination
of literacy and knowledge, okay? So what
scholars believe is
these various factors will coalesce
into the Renaissance and mark an
intellectual revolution in Europe.
Right? Now,
the thing that you
will remember about my teaching in this
class is I disagree
with scholarship. I think there's one
factor that they're missing out and it's
the main factor in the creation of the
Renaissance.
I believe I will argue to you today that
Dante, The Divine Comedy, is what
ultimately sparked the Renaissance.
Without Dante, the Renaissance, this
revolution would not have been possible,
okay? So, this class, I'm going to
present you the scholarly mainstream
argument, and then I will present my
argument, which is that Dante is most
responsible for the Renaissance, okay?
Um
some
a basic fact that we need to remember.
If you look at all the major figures of
the Renaissance, okay, including
Raphael, Galileo,
um
uh
Boccaccio,
uh Michelangelo, okay? The person
who was born the earliest
is actually
Dante, okay, in 1265.
So, that is a good clue to suggest that
perhaps it was Dante that sparked the
Renaissance, that he's the uh secret
sauce that made the Renaissance
possible, okay? And throughout this
class, I will make you uh this argument.
But first, let's go just go over through
the
scholarly mainstream argument, okay? So,
um first thing to remember that is that
before the Renaissance, Europe was was
connected with Africa, uh Asia, and the
Middle East uh through these dense trade
networks. As we discussed previously,
the three main uh city-states that are
involved in global trade are um
Venice, okay?
Genoa and Florence. Venice and Genoa are
the ones who benefit the most from this
trade because they are by the coast, and
they're the ones that that are most
strategically located to benefit from
this trade.
Okay? And this trade, mainly slave
trade, actually, uh so Genoa and Venice
were engaged mainly in slave trade.
Florence will not engage in slave trade.
It will engage mainly in wool, okay?
Wool.
Um so this is Venice and the slave trade
made Venice extremely prosperous. This
is Florence in around the 15th century.
Okay. So, um one thing to remember about
Italy at this point is that it's divided
into warring city-states, okay? And as a
result, they're always in competition
with each other. They're always at war
with each other. And as we discussed
previously, this scenario will drive
innovation in Europe.
Okay? Mainly commercial innovation.
By the By about the year 1000, as we
discussed last class, Europe um is now
prosperous and they are engaging in
commercial trade. The problem is how do
you facilitate trade, right? So, for
example, if England has a lot of cotton
and then France has a lot of
um bananas,
what if England doesn't want bananas?
Well, England and France cannot trade
with with each other. So, the only way
to get around this is by creating a
currency that everyone wants. And the
currency that everyone wants is gold.
So, in Florence, they create something
called a gold florin, which is the
currency of
uh Florence, but because it is so um
prestigious, because it's mainly gold,
everyone wants it. And so, the gold
florin becomes the currency of European
trade.
And the family that most benefits from
uh the status of the florin is the
Medici Medici family, okay? So, this is
Cosimo, the basic the founding patriarch
of the family. And so, what he would do
is
he will pull the resources of rich
people in Florence and to create a bank.
Meaning, if you're a merchant, you can
borrow from uh this bank. And what he
would do is he would set up branches
all throughout Europe in order to
facilitate and underwrite European
trade.
Okay? And obviously, he gets a cut of
all this trade. As a result, the Medici
family become tremendously wealthy. And
they create the Medici dynasty. From
this family, four Popes will emerge.
Okay? Four Popes will emerge. They will
eventually take over Florence and create
their own monarchy. As we discussed, if
you're a merchant family,
you have a legitimacy problem. You
didn't uh win the title you didn't win
your wealth on the battlefield. You
don't represent God. All you All you
have is a lot of money. So, in order to
legitimize themselves, they will go on a
massive spending spree
in order to make Florence the cultural
capital of Europe. Okay? So, they will
First of all,
fund these massive uh cultural projects.
Uh the most famous church in Florence is
called the Santa Maria del Fiore. It's
still there. You guys can still visit
it. It's the fourth largest church in
the world. It's absolutely stunning,
okay?
Here's a Here's another view of the
church and the city of Florence. And
it's still there today. If you fly to
Florence, you will still see this
picture, okay? It is incredibly well
preserved. This is what inside the
church looks like.
All right?
They will also patronize
um artists.
The most famous artists of this time
were patronized by the Medici family.
So, Michelangelo
um
wa- actually lived
with the Medici family for a while. And
of course, he's most famous for a
painting called The Creation of Adam,
which will which we will discuss, okay?
The Creation of Adam. He's also famous
for the statue of David.
All right?
You also have Da Vinci, who is
considered the,
um, archetypal Renaissance man. You when
you think of the Renaissance, you think
of Da Vinci, okay? So, uh, these are
some of his paintings.
He is a remarkable genius. He is what we
call a polymath, which means that he
dabbles or he's interested in every
single field of human knowledge. The
sciences, philosophy, poetry, art,
music, everything. And he takes all
these different disciplines and combines
them into his art.
Okay? This is one of his most famous
paintings, The Last Supper. And this
painting, I will show you, is a work of
genius. Okay? So, later on, we will
actually discuss The Last Supper, but
first I introduce it to you here.
Um, this is The School of Athens by
Raphael,
um, one one of the most famous paintings
in the world.
You also have, uh, Botticelli.
Um, Donatello.
Um, and again, these are,
um,
the most famous artists of the
Renaissance, and the Medicis patronized
every single one of them. Later on in
this class, we will actually discuss
these paintings. But, um, as
the Medicis are patronizing,
um,
art and culture in Florence, the
printing press is being invented by
Gutenberg in Germany. And the And the
printing press, it marks a revolution
uh, of literacy in Europe, okay? This is
a picture of what a printing shop looks
like, okay?
So, um think about this.
So, the printing press first arrives in
Venice in 1469.
Uh only 30 years later, there are 417
printing presses in the city. Think of
these as publishing houses.
All right?
Um in the first 50 years,
there are 20 million volumes of books
that are printed
in Europe. So, the printing press
is a
uh
revolution of literacy and knowledge in
Europe that democratizes knowledge.
Everyone now has access to Plato,
Aristotle, the Bible.
And what they're reading are some of the
major thinkers of the Renaissance. So,
in
in terms of poetry, there are three
major
uh poets. There's Dante,
there's Petrarch, and there's Boccaccio.
All right?
You also have uh Niccolò Machiavelli,
who we still read today. Um his most
famous work is called The Prince. And
The Prince is really one of the first
political treatises in the world. The
question then is, how do you best govern
um a state? And today we remember We
remember The Prince for its strategy,
for its almost immoral strategy on how
to rule a state. What we need to
remember is that Machiavelli himself,
during his time, he was a staunch
democrat. He believed that the people
needed um to have a say over the affairs
of Florence. And as a result, he came
into conflict with the Medicis, who
tortured him, okay? But he wrote The
Prince in order to raise awareness about
politics. He believed that if we are to
have a well-functioning republic, then
everyone needs to understand how
politics works, okay?
And then you also have from Florence uh
Galileo, who uh we will discuss
uh next week. He is the father of
science,
okay? So, these are the major thinkers
of the Renaissance. Um the philosophy,
the value system that underpins all this
artistic production, is the idea of
humanism, okay? So, what is humanism?
And how is it different from
um Christianity, okay? So, these are the
three major differences, guys, okay? So,
let's let's look at them.
If you're Christian, the Catholic Church
for the longest time struggled with what
is the nature, what is the idea of God?
Okay?
And humanists
concern themselves with what is the
story of humans.
Okay, do you guys understand? This is
the major revolution in the intellect uh
brought on by the Renaissance. A
transition from
a focus on ideas to a focus on stories.
Second major difference is
Christians always ask, how do I save my
soul? How do I ensure that I go to
heaven?
But humanists ask, how do I flourish?
How do I make the most out of my
talents? How do I have the best possible
life on Earth, okay? So, the Greek word
is eudaimonia.
All right? So, humanism is actually a
return to the values and belief systems
of classical Greece.
The the major difference is um
Christians are always asked, "How can we
best serve God? How can we best obey
God?" But human humanists ask, "How do
we achieve goodness? How do we make the
world we live in today beautiful and
truthful?" Okay? So, these are the three
major differences that separate
Christians from humanists.
And what this and what humanism will
represent is a radical reorient reorient
reorient Sorry, reorientation
of
focus from
the afterworld into the here and now.
Okay?
Christians care about what happens in
heaven. Humanists care about what
happens today. How do we make the most
out of today? How do we make the world a
better place?
Okay?
Does that make sense to you guys?
All right.
So,
having said that, let's
understand concretely how this
transition happened. It happened mainly
through art. Okay? So, the main transi-
transition
uh
to emphasize is a transition from a
focus on ideas to a focus on stories.
So, what what do I mean by that? Okay,
let's look at some classical Greek
sculptures. If you look at some Greek
sculptures, the thing that stands out is
the motion, the tension, the emotion in
the sculptures, right? There's a story
being told.
You can almost feel that this person is
alive and thinking. All right? You can
almost go into this person's character.
It's a story.
This sculpture is actually even more
obvious, right? Within the sculpture,
there's a story taking place. It's
almost like you're watching a movie. And
what your mind does when it's looking at
the sculpture, when it is in
conversation with the sculpture, it is
imagine what happens before and after.
You are making the sculpture alive with
your imagination.
Okay?
So, that's classical Greece. By the time
we hit medieval Christianity, the very
concept of art changes. It becomes more
of an idea. Okay? So, this is this is
from the Carolingian Renaissance. Okay?
So, basically the beginning of the Holy
Roman Empire. And as you can see,
the artwork, it's much more static.
Okay? There's not really a story here.
What's being conveyed to you is an idea.
You don't really have to imagine what's
going on because there's really no space
for you to imagine what's going on.
Okay?
So, the main artwork
during the medieval uh Christian period
are stained glass windows. So, you go
inside a church and you see pictures on
the windows. And what these are are
almost like visual aids. So, when the
priest is talking about the stories of
the Bible, he's using these
um pictures to illustrate his point
because remember, at this point, most
people are illiterate.
Because of these stained glass windows,
the effect that is created um in the
observer is blinding and awesome.
Remember, these are windows and they're
high up in the church. So, the light is
coming through. It makes the pictures
wholly illuminated with light. It's
awesome. You're You're forced to stand
back. But, it's also blinding. Blinding
just means that it's hard for you to
imagine what's going on.
The purpose of these um of this artwork
is to make you submit
before the power of God. For you to
understand the awesomeness
of
God. Okay? Does that make sense? You're
not here to participate, you're here to
submit.
All right? So, as you can see, this is a
church. You can see how the light comes
in and it blinds you.
Right? And it's hard for you to really
participate in the artwork. So, this is
the idea of medieval Christianity. The
idea
that you, through artwork, you are
trying to represent the eternity.
The awesomeness, the mystery that is
God.
All right?
By the time we hit the Renaissance,
the attitude is completely different.
Okay? This is Da Vinci's The Last
Supper.
And from blinding and awesome, we go to
compelling and curious.
What this means is compelling means that
you are drawn into the picture.
All right? Why? Because of depth. Okay?
Meaning the picture moves backwards and
it moves forwards.
And because of this motion,
you are drawn into the picture. Look at
this table, right? Look at this table.
It's not a complete table. It's too much
too small for 13 people to eat. It's
much too thin, right? So, what your eye
believes is this table is expanding
outwards, and so you are part of this
picture.
Does that make sense?
Okay? And also, it's curious because
clearly within this picture, there's a
lot of tension. You see how these
different groups are in discussion.
Okay? And they're all focused on Jesus.
So, this This the picture, the artwork
of the Last Supper. In the Last Supper,
which appears in the Bible,
Jesus reveals that someone has
betrayed them.
There's someone, uh, his name is Judas
Iscariot. He has betrayed them
and,
um, the next day Jesus will be arrested
and he will be crucified.
And once Jesus announces this,
everyone,
um, becomes anxious. "Is it me? Is it
me? Am I the betrayer?" Okay? There's a
lot of tension in this, uh, picture. And
as you can see, it's a radical
departure.
This very painting is a radical
departure from medieval Christian art.
If you look at previous medieval
Christian art, okay, below, um, first of
all, it's much more static. It's much
more organized.
There's not that much tension in the
picture. And what's most important is
the idea of holiness. You see this halo
surrounding each person in the picture,
right?
It shows you that these are divine
figures. What Leo Leonardo da Vinci has
done, which is very important, is he's
really he's really taking out of the
human he's really taking out the
humanity in the picture. There are no
halos. What's left is the humanity.
Okay? These are first and foremost
humans, not divine figures.
Okay, so this is another picture
previously. So there's much more detail,
but as you again, as you can see, not as
much tension, not as much, uh, drama as
in the Vin- da Vinci's.
All right, and this is the most recent.
Okay? This is the most recent. Now, in,
uh, this, uh, artwork, Judas Iscariot
stands out
from the rest. And so that signals him
as the betrayer.
But in
da Vinci's work, it's not obvious who is
the betrayer. Everyone is
um afraid that he or she is the
betrayer.
Okay? And then that this And what this
does is it forces you to investigate. It
forces you, the observer, to observe the
details in order in order to figure out
who is who.
All right?
What's amazing about this picture is the
focus on human anatomy,
facial expressions.
Right? You see the tensions in the neck.
You see the hand gestures. So, what um
Da Vinci believed is that the hands
the hand motions, they are a window into
the soul of a person.
Okay? If you want to understand how a
person thinks, you see how
he or she uses
the hands, okay? And you can see how the
hands are all in different motions,
which signifies different personalities,
different thoughts inside that person.
And again, you're forced to investigate.
All right? You can see the anxiety, the
stress, the drama in each of the faces.
Da Vinci was first and foremost
an astute observer of
emotions.
Okay? How emotions are expressed through
the face, through body tension, through
breathing, through the eyes.
Um the man who is who ultimately
responsible for the betrayal is Judas
Iscariot. And you can see
how Dante sublimely Sorry, subtly with
with with subtlety
emphasizes his betrayal, right? Okay, so
you can see how he's darker than the
other individuals. So, he's turning away
from the light. He's betrayed God by
turning away from the light. Okay? Also,
um
in his hand, he's clutching
uh some silver coins, okay?
And you can see his neck. His neck is
being emphasized. Why? Because of the
tension in his neck, okay? He can't
breathe. Everyone else is anxious.
They're talking, but he cannot bring
himself to talk. So, all the tension is
captured in his neck.
Okay?
All right. So, you see all the subtlety
here, right?
Okay.
Something really fun about um the the
Last Supper is becomes up the basis for
a very famous book called The Da Vinci
Code.
And And The Da Vinci Code is a very
popular book. No scholarship. It's just
meant for entertainment. What it argues
is that Jesus did not die
um
I'm sorry. Jesus died.
But before he died, he married his
lover, who is Mary
uh
Mag- Magdalene, okay? And so, this
picture becomes one of the sources for
the book. So, um
previously, scholars have believed that
this person is one of the apostles. But
when you look at him,
okay? It turns out
she's it's almost a she, right? Okay?
And if you look at how Jesus and this
person is stationed, it creates an M
shape, right? An M can mean married. But
it stands for their closeness together.
So, um people speculate that
these two are married. And by doing
this, what
Da Vinci is really emphasizing is the
humanity
of Jesus. Jesus is first and foremost a
human.
Okay? So, this is this is interesting,
guys. Okay? Scholars don't really agree
with this analysis, but becomes the
basis of The Da Vinci Code, which is a
really fun book. All right.
Something that
um scholars do believe is the
mathematics. So, if you look at where
the hands and the bread are, and you map
it onto a music sheet, you can actually
play the music.
Okay?
It's designed to be musical. Also, look
at the configuration. It's a 3 3 1 3 3
configuration, okay? It turns out, if
you look at the Bible and you look for
the passage 33:133,
you get this quotation in Lamentations,
okay, in the Bible. It says, "For no one
is cast off by the Lord forever. Though
he brings grief, he will show
compassion. So great is his unfailing
love. For he does not willingly bring
affliction or grief to anyone."
And so, the idea here is that God will
always love you. God is love.
God is incapable of hating you. Okay? He
will always find a way to forgive you.
And if you remember from last semester,
this is the very idea of The Divine
Comedy.
Okay? Leonardo da Vinci is getting this
idea from Dante. And this idea is the
backbone of The Last Supper. Jesus knows
he's been betrayed by Judas Iscariot,
but look at him, okay? Let's go back and
look at him. He's calm. He's reassured.
He's already forgiven Judas Iscariot.
All right? There's no hatred in him.
There's no anger.
The anger and the hatred
um is everyone else. All right?
So, that's The Last Supper. And as you
can see,
it is heavily influenced by uh Dante.
All right.
This is the most famous painting in the
world, the Mona Lisa.
Um it has captured the imagination of
millions of people. Millions of people
every year will go to France, the
Louvre, to stand in line just so they
can spend 10 seconds to look at this
picture, okay?
What makes this picture remarkable is
it's secretly alive.
When you Donny spent 16 years crafting
this in a way that by just talking with
it, by moving around in conversation
with it, it becomes alive.
So, when you just look at it directly,
Mona Lisa isn't really doing anything.
She's just smiling. So, I So, this she's
she's she's neutral in her expression,
right? But if you turn away from her,
what happens is this.
What happens is she starts to have a
smile.
Okay?
She starts to have a smile. So,
your eyes play tricks on you. When you
move away from the picture, what happens
is your peripheral peripheral vision
still picks up the picture, but the
expression is different, okay? So, this
is the central version when you just
look at her directly, but as you move
further away from her, she smiles.
Okay? So, what what is this saying? What
this is saying is
the
art is alive if you engage with it.
Okay? Art is not meant to be blinding
and awesome. It's meant to be here and
now. Only if you participate in the art
does it become alive. Only
what when it becomes alive does it it
does it achieve its true meaning, okay?
So, this is the Mona Lisa.
All right. Let's look at the School of
Athens by Raphael.
Um
the the actual name for this painting is
actually not School of Athens. It's
actually called philosophy. And the
reason why is
it was commissioned by Pope Julius II of
the Vatican
in order to decorate his papal
apartments. So, if you go inside his
apart- papal apartments today, there are
four major
frescoes, paintings.
The first is called philosophy, and then
right beside philosophy is called
religion. Okay? So, religion and
philosophy balance each other out. They
are dependent on each other. And then
across the wall uh are two more
paintings.
Poetry
and law.
All right? So, that's the very ideal of
um the Renaissance, open-mindedness,
exploration,
and
holistic learning.
All right. So, let's look at this
painting. First of all, at the very
center are two figures,
Plato and Aristotle.
How do we know? Because they're holding
two books. This is the Timaeus by Plato,
where he discusses
um the realm of the forms. Remember
before in class we discussed Platonic
philosophy, right? And how um
Plato conceptualizes heaven. God is the
form of the good, and then form of the
good will will emanate
um concepts, truth, beauty, justice,
which will then give rise to perfect
forms.
Okay? And so, this is
um argued in his book Timaeus.
Aristotle,
his most famous book is called Ethics,
How to Lead a Good Life.
What's amazing about this picture is you
can see that these two are having a
debate.
So, uh first thing is Plato's pointing
upwards, okay? He's What he's saying is
the real world, what matters is heaven.
And what Aristotle is saying is no, what
matters is down here on Earth.
Okay?
Aristotle is concerned about
um earthly matters.
Also,
look at their uh colors. So,
Plato is wearing white
and
red. White symbolizes air.
Red symbolizes fire, right? These are
spiritual colors.
But,
Aristotle is wearing blue, which
signifies water.
And then, he's also wearing brown, which
signifies the earth.
Okay?
So, they're having this debate. And this
debate is uh as we discussed previously,
it is what underpins the debate within
Western philosophy even today.
Okay?
Now, what's amazing is that as the two
are walking, all right, they're
splitting the world into two, right?
There There are those philosophers who
support Aristotle and they focus on
earthly matters.
And then, there are people who support
Plato who focus on spiritual matters on
discovering the secrets of the universe.
All right? Aristotle is concerned about
um everyday science on uncovering the
secrets of our reality.
Okay, so they're splitting into two.
And as you can see, there is depth to
this painting, okay? There's a sky to
the back. There are these arches. And
so, it's extending forward and so, we're
being drawn into the picture. That's the
power of depth and perception.
Um
this is Pythagoras. Uh you will know him
from from Pythagoras uh theorem, but
he's first and foremost a spiritualist.
He's concerned about mysticism. He's
concerned about
um God. Uh this is Euclid, okay, who is
uh the one of the inventors of geometry.
All right? And here, he's focused on
using science, using logic, using
deduction to teach his students.
You also have in the picture many
different personalities. You have
Zoroaster, who is the founder of
Zoroastrianism.
Okay, the religion of Persia. You have
Ptolemy, who investigated how
the planets move, right? And as you can
see,
Zoroaster Can you see this picture
clearly? Okay. This is more clear.
Zoroaster is concerned with the heavens,
with spiritual matters.
Ptolemy is concerned with the Earth,
with all reality.
All right? So, this is Raphael
acknowledging that there are two
different realities. There's the
material reality, but then there's also
a spiritual reality, and they're both
important. All right? Now, what's
amazing here is that Raphael, this is
Raphael actually. This is a
self-portrait of Raphael. He will
actually engage
in the conversation. He will listen in.
He will insert himself in the painting.
Okay? Now, remember that Christianity
focuses on the idea of humility, on
self-negation, on removing yourself
from the world. But, Raphael is
reinserting himself into the world and
celebrating his curiosity, celebrating
his humanity.
Okay?
And where did he get this idea from?
From Dante, right? Because Dante makes
himself the hero of the Divine Comedy.
He makes himself the focus of the Divine
Comedy.
And to go back to the conversation
between Plato and Aristotle,
look at this, okay? This is a
visual representation of the Divine
Comedy. Because remember, in the Divine
Comedy, Virgil and Dante are engaged in
a vigorous debate about the nature of
love, the nature of sin, right?
Okay? So, this is representing The
Divine Comedy. The structure is the same
as The Divine Comedy. They're also as
they walk
from Purgatory
from Inferno to Purgatory, they're also
talking to other historical figures as
well.
All right? So, this is directly inspired
by Dante.
Does it make sense to you guys?
Okay, so this is Raphael. Okay? So, not
only does Raphael insert himself into
the picture, he also inserts his friend
Michelangelo. Okay? This is
Michelangelo. Mic- Michelangelo is known
for being reclusive. He's known for not
enjoying the company of others.
And Michelangelo here, he's conflated
with another historical figure, a
philosopher named Heraclitus, who is
also known for not enjoying the company
of of others.
Okay? So, this picture to shows you the
immense diversity of human thought and
human personality. It's a sub- sublation
of what it means to be human. Okay? So,
these paintings leave us with a
fundamental question.
All right? We can now see the radical
differences between Christian art and
Renaissance art. So, now the question
then is
how did Dante spark the confident
self-exploration and triumphant
self-expression of the Renaissance? You
look at the art, it is confident.
Uh it is triumphant. Okay? It's
celebrating what it means to be human.
And what I will show you now is what he
will do is he will reimagine our
relationship with God, which is a
fundamental question of Europe at this
time. Okay. So, most people they're
grappling with three major questions,
especially intellectuals.
The first question is, what is God?
Okay? What is the idea? What is the
nature of God? Second question is, what
is the nature of the relationship
between God and humans? Why did God
create us? What is our responsibility to
God? Okay? And the last question is, how
can we best worship God? Meaning, how
can we best ensure our divinity? How can
we best ensure that we will rise to
heaven?
All right? So, these are three
fundamental questions
underlying Christian society at this
point.
All right? So,
um
you can take these three questions and
just ask one question really, which is,
why did Jesus have to die?
Why was Jesus crucified?
Okay? This is the
crucifixion, okay?
Why is it that the son of God, the
Messiah, had to die?
And this idea was first
understood and discussed by Paul. Okay?
And Paul's idea is this,
God created us and gave us paradise.
Okay? This is Adam and Eve in the Garden
of Eden. But because
we were arrogant, because we were proud,
we want to become God, we want to eat
that food
from the tree of knowledge, which
which would make us like God. And
because we disobeyed God, God had no
choice but to banish us
from the Garden of Eden, okay?
And so, why did Jesus have to come to
Earth and sacrifice himself?
Because
um
without God, we humans can only commit
more and more sin. So, to redeem us
and to beg for for for forgiveness from
God, Jesus came down and sacrificed
himself.
Okay? And the sacrifice
um made God relent and forgive us.
And so now we are cleansed of our sins,
and now we can begin anew.
All right? That's the idea that Paul is
presenting. Why Jesus is the Messiah,
and why he had to kill himself.
The problem though is
as Christianity grows and grows, the
divinity of Christ, the divinity of
Jesus, expands. Before he was just a
human who was favored by God. Then he
became a son of God. But by the time of
a man named Tertullian, who lived about
the 2nd century, he argued for the Holy
Trinity, which is that God, Jesus, and
the Holy Spirit are separate, but equal.
Jesus is God.
Okay? Now you have a problem now. If
Jesus truly God, then why did God have
to kill himself? We can understand if
Jesus is the son of God, Jesus kills
himself to
beg for his father's forgiveness. That
makes sense. All right? But if Jesus is
God, then why did he have to kill
himself? Okay? This this This is now
causing a lot of confusion. So another
Christian theologian by the name of
Origen,
Origen, okay, so this is the Trinity,
right?
By name Origen,
he his explanation is something called
the ransom theory. All right? And the
theory goes like this.
When we were cast off from the Garden of
Eden, we became
uh subject to Satan, the devil. We
became slaves to the devil. Remember it
was it was Satan, the devil, who tempted
Eve to eat that fruit, right? And when
she ate that fruit, she now swears
allegiance to devil. We are now slaves
to the devil. We are now his property.
So the only way for God to redeem us
is by ransoming us from Satan. By
offering something so valuable that
Satan is willing to make a trade, right?
So, what did God offer? God offered his
life.
The trick though is that God cannot be
killed because God is eternal and
perfect. So, God tricked Satan. But,
what's really important to understand is
this, before we were slaves to Satan,
but by because God made this trade, we
are now slaves to God. Okay?
We are now slaves to God.
And this very idea will be expanded and
elaborated
by Augustine in order to create
intellectual blueprint
for the Catholic Church, all right? This
idea of the ransom theory.
All right. So, remember City of God, um
Augustine will say certain things. It's
really important for us to remember what
he said in the City of God. Okay? The
main idea is that we are because God
ransomed us, we are now his slaves. And
therefore, we must obey him. We must
submit. All right. So, let's go over
what he says, Augustine.
First thing he says is,
"When man lives by the standard of man,
when we trust ourselves, when we use our
imagination, when we use our intuition,
and not by the standard of God." The
standard of God is to submit to him, to
obey him.
"He is like the devil, okay? You
understand? When we When we use our
imagination, when we use our intuition,
we are like Satan.
At our core is the essence of Satan.
It is only by submitting ourselves to
God that we are freed from the influence
of Satan, okay?
Could anything but pride happen at the
start of the evil will? Why did we
disobey God? Why did we eat that fruit?
Because we want to become God. So,
there's an arrogance, there's a there's
a pride to us that is the essence of
Satan, okay? Satan fell from heaven
because of his pride. We if if we just
trust our nature, we will also fall like
Satan.
His was a venial transgression when he
refused to desert his life's companion,
even though the refusal entailed
companionship in sin.
Eve was tempted by
the devil.
But Adam
ate the fruit because of his love for
Eve.
Therefore, love can only misguide you.
Love can only trick you. Love can only
lead you to an evil path. Okay? Do not
trust your intuition. Do not trust your
imagination. But most importantly, do
not trust your love of others,
especially
woman. Okay?
The will derives its existence as a
nature from its creation by God. It's
falling away from its true being is due
to its creation out of nothing. Okay?
So, why are we like the Why are we like
um
the devil? Why can't we trust ourselves?
Because we were created out of dust. We
were created out of nothing.
All right? If we're an angel, we're
created by God, and therefore we are
perfect. But because we're created out
of dust,
we are inherently flawed.
Okay? So, we must not trust ourselves.
We must refuse who we are. We must deny
who we are and submit ourselves to the
glory that is God. All right?
We see the two cities were created by
two kinds of love. The earthly city was
created by self-love reaching the point
of contempt for God. When we love
ourselves, we disobey God, and that's
what explains the world we live in
today.
This world is evil
because of our pride, because of our
self-love, because of love for others.
But the heavenly city by the love of God
carried as far as contempt of self. When
we deny who we are,
when we submit fully to God, we can
create a perfect world. We can achieve
heaven.
Okay? So, again, this is the very idea
um for the Catholic Church. Self-denial,
self-negation.
Okay?
Now, you can think about this and
understand now why
the Islamic world raced ahead of Europe.
Because in Europe, people were
paralyzed. People were afraid to do
anything because they couldn't really
trust themselves.
Okay?
And but eventually, the contrast between
the Islamic world and the European
Christian world were so great that even
the Catholic Church had to admit there
were problems with the theology of
Augustine.
Okay? If you ask people to deny who they
are and to
submit themselves completely to the
power of the church, it leads to
corruption, stagnation, and inequality.
Okay? So, there are some major reforms
undertaken by the church in response to
this. Uh one major reform are the
creation of the university system. So,
this is the University of Paris, which
is chartered in 1200. This This today is
called the Sorbonne, okay, which is the
most famous
um university in
France and in Europe, basically. Um
One of the most famous professors of
theology at the University of Paris is
Thomas Aquinas. And the Thomas Aquinas,
he's a saint in the Catholic Church. His
importance is he's trying to revise
Augustine
for
um a Europe in conflict with Islam.
Okay? What What he's really trying to do
is he's trying to take the pure Platonic
world of Augustine and combine it with
Aristotelian science and logic and
reason. He's trying to combine faith and
reason. Okay? And
um so, he's going to update the Catholic
Church.
But ultimately, he doesn't succeed. And
the reason why is people don't really
understand what he's trying to do. Also,
Augustine has been in power for like
centuries. And so, he's really become
part of the culture, the milieu of
Europe. Okay? He's in the air you
breathe.
That's the power of culture.
The man who ultimately free Europe from
the grasp of Augustine is actually
Dante.
And Dante will do so
by through his poetry. Through his
poetry, he's going to reimagine the
human relationship with God.
Okay?
So, in The Divine Comedy, he will make
certain assertions.
The first major assertion is this.
Okay, guys? Let's read together. The
greatest gift to to the magnanimity of
God, as he created, gave the gift most
suited to his goodness, gift that he
most prizes was the freedom of the will.
Okay? So, what this is saying is this.
When God created us, to show his
generosity, to show that he's perfect,
to show his goodness, he gave us the
gift that only God can give us, the gift
that he most prizes, which is the
freedom from him.
Right? You are off God, but now you are
free of God. You can do whatever you
want.
All right? So, that's one of the central
ideas
of the The Divine Comedy. That
what makes us fundamentally human is
freedom of the will, that we can choose
the life we lead.
Right?
All right.
So, let's let's study The Divine Comedy.
Uh this is this is going to be Canto 7
of Paradise. And in this canto,
Beatrice, remember they're both in
heaven, Beatrice and Dante are engaged
in a intellectual discussion. The
question that they're trying to figure
out is why did Jesus have to kill
himself? Okay?
Remember before Paul suggested it was to
redeem us from original sin and then
Origen's uh and then Or- um
um
Origen suggested the idea of the ransom
theory, okay?
Um God had to redeem us, ransom us from
Satan. Now, what's it What what Dante is
going to do is he's going to propose a
new theory.
And this new theory is going to
radically
reimagine our relationship with God,
okay? So, so let's look at this very
closely.
You say, this is Beatrice talking to
Dante, "What I've heard is clear to me,
but this is hidden from me. Why God
willed precisely this pathway for
redemption, okay?
Okay, God wants to save us, but why did
God have to kill himself?"
That's the question here.
That makes no sense, okay? If you're not
a If you're non-Christian, it's almost
impossible to explain to someone else
who's not a Christian why Jesus had to
die, right? It makes no sense.
"Brother, this ordinance is buried from
the eyes of everyone whose intellect has
not matured within the flame of love."
Okay? This is And Beatrice is making
this argument, which is like you can
only understand this if you truly love
someone.
It's only through love that you can
acquire wisdom.
You can acquire empathy and imagination.
Right?
"The godly goodness that has banished
every envy from its own self burns in
itself and sparkling so it shows eternal
beauties." Remember last semester we
discussed the nature of God. God is love
itself. There can be no hate, there can
be no envy, there can be no blemishes
within the nature of God, okay?
"All that derives directly from goodness
is everlasting since the seal of
goodness impresses an imprint that never
alters. So, God when God creates, what
he creates is also perfect.
Only man's sin and no man's liberty
makes him unlike the highest good so
that in him the brightness of his light
is dimmed, okay? So, God is in us. God
is the light that burns in us and allows
us to love others. When we love others,
the bright the brightness burns
brighter.
The light burns brighter.
Okay? That's how we celebrate God by
loving others.
We also have the freedom of the will,
okay? So, these are the two things that
God has given us. Freedom to choose,
freedom freedom to live the lives we
want to to to live, and as well as
the power to love and to imagine.
But, these things come into conflict
when we choose to to bad.
When we choose to disobey, when we
choose to commit sin, we are turning
away from God and therefore dampening
the brightness in us.
Okay? We're purposely stuffing out the
flame in us.
And man cannot regain his dignity unless
where sin left emptiness, man fills that
void with just a man's for evil
pleasure, okay? So, when you commit sin,
you must make amends. You must force
yourself. You must choose to go on the
proper path and make amends.
But, for when your nature sinned so
totally within its seed, then from these
dignities, just as from paradise, that
nature parted. Okay? Sometimes you could
commit a sin that's so terrible, the
light leaves you.
And that's when we disobeyed God in the
Garden of Eden.
That sin, the original sin, was so
terrible that Adam drew all his progeny
to darkness.
Okay?
And they could never be regained, if you
consider carefully, by any way that did
not pass across one of these two forts,
okay? So, how do we forgive? How do we
ask for forgiveness, okay? There are two
possibilities.
Either through nothing other than his
mercy, God had to pardon man, or of
himself, man had to proffer payment for
his fault, okay? So, there are two ways
for us to get that light back in us, to
redeem ourselves in the eyes of God. The
first way is if God just forgives us. If
God says, "I'm
total I'm perfect I'm total perfectness
I forgive you. Because that's what I do,
I forgive you."
To show mercy. That's one possibility.
But when he does that, the problem is
we've learned nothing. We haven't grown,
okay?
Another possibility is if we
figure out a way
to redeem ourselves. If we make amends.
If we give God all the gold in the
world.
Okay?
But because our crime was so great,
because we denied the love of God,
nothing we do There's There's nothing we
could give God that would redeem us from
our sin, okay? That's a conflict here.
That's a paradox. God cannot forgive us,
because if he did so, we would not grow
and learn.
And there's nothing we can do to
redeem ourselves in the eyes of God,
because our crime was so great. So,
that's the paradox.
Man's limits could not recompensate
for no obedience, no humility he offered
later could not been so deep that it
could match the heights he meant to
reach through disobedience. Man lacked
the power to offer satisfaction by
himself.
We want to kill God.
That was the original sin. We wanted to
eat that food, become God, and then kill
God, and become God itself.
That's the greatest crime.
So, how can you redeem yourself?
How can you ask for forgiveness
if the crime is to kill God?
Right?
For God showed great a generosity in
giving his own self that men might be
able to rise than if he simply pardoned.
Okay? So, for thousands of years, God
had to think of a way to
redeem us,
forgive us, but at the same time ensure
we would not do anything like this ever
again.
Okay? And the path he chose was to
sacrifice himself.
For every other means fell short of
justice except the way whereby the Son
of God humbled himself when he became
incarnate, okay? So,
I'm going to use a metaphor to explain
this idea. It it it it it it's it's a
very it's not a great metaphor, but I
think this will illustrate what Peter is
saying here about God.
Let's just have a daughter named Eve. I
have a a a a favorite favorite dog named
Johnny. I love Johnny, and I love Eve. I
love both, okay?
I say to Eve, "Johnny is my favorite
um dog. You're my favorite favorite
favorite daughter. I love you both."
Eve, because she's young and she's
stupid, she decides, "I only want my
father's love me." So, Eve purposely
kills my dog Johnny.
All right?
Now,
what do I do?
I'm Eve's father. If I just say, "Eve,
don't worry about it. You're young. It
was a mistake."
Eve is probably going to go hurt someone
else, right? I have to teach her a
lesson.
But,
if I hit her, if I punish her,
then
that might suggest to Eve I don't really
love her.
It doesn't make sense. That's That's a
paradox here. That's That's a conflict.
And so, what I choose to do after many
weeks of intense thinking is I choose to
punish myself on behalf of Eve.
Okay? I take a bat and I hit myself or I
take a whip and I hit myself, and then
my hand is bleeding, and Eve watches
this.
And you can see
that when Eve sees this, she has to cry.
She has to cry and feel remorse for what
she
uh did, and she also cries because she
knows I truly love her.
Okay? So, that's what Peter is saying
here. God loves us so much that he's
willing to everything in order to teach
us to be better human beings. Okay?
That's the power of God.
All right.
All right. So, the conversation
continues,
and this story makes sense, but it's
also going to create a lot of problems.
Okay? One major problem is if God
created us,
and God loves us,
why are we making mistakes?
Why are we dying? Why are we in pain?
Okay? And this is what Peter says.
You say, "I see that water, see that
fire and air and earth and all that they
compose come corruption and endure so
briefly." Okay? So, in this world there
is death, there's dying, there's pain,
there's suffering. Why is that?
And yet these two were things created if
what has been said above is true, then
these things never should be subject to
corruption. If whatever If whatever God
creates is perfect,
then things shouldn't die.
All right?
Brother,
the angels in the pure country
where you are now, these may be said to
be created as they are in all their
being. Okay? Yes, it is true that God
created everything in this world, but
there's a problem. There's a difference.
Whereas the elements that you have
mentioned, as well as those things that
are made from them, receive their form
from a created power,
the matter they contain had been created
just as within the stars that wheel
around them, the power to give form had
been created. The rays and motion of the
holy lights draw forth the soul of every
animal and plant from matter able to
take form, okay? So, what this is saying
is this, God did not create animals and
plants. God created the laws of the
universe. He created the atoms.
The essence that would give rise to
animals and plants.
And so, they're not perfect, okay? The
laws are perfect. The holy light is
perfect, but not the creation from the
holy light.
And this creation was meant to die so
that new creations can come out, okay?
Right? When a animal
uh dies, the atoms break away, and then
a new form comes into being, okay?
That's the law of the universe. So,
that's perfect, but not the animals and
plants are perfect.
But your life is brief formed
immediately by the chief good who so
enamors it of its own self that it
desires him always. Okay, so now the
question then is, if animals and plants
aren't perfect,
what are humans then?
Right?
So, we
Okay, and this is what
she says. So, reasoning, you can also
can deduce your resurrection. You need
but remember the way in which your human
flesh was fashioned when both of the
first parents were created. Okay, so
this is the trick.
You have to remember this.
Animals and plants are created from the
laws of the universe, which God created.
Angels are created by
God
himself, and therefore the angels are
perfect. We humans have a dual nature.
We are both created from the laws of the
universe, and we are both created by God
itself.
All right?
Because when
God created Adam, God created him from
out of dust, okay? But then what God did
was breathe life into him.
So the essence of God is within Adam,
and therefore us.
Our bodies are mortal, but our souls are
immortal.
Our souls have the essence of God, which
is love. The more we love, the more the
light burns in us.
And as light burns in us,
it will allow for our
resurrection, okay?
Because the matter
will
regenerate.
The soul is eternal.
Okay? So, that's what Dante is saying
here. The best way to celebrate God is
by loving others. When you love others,
you're activating your imagination.
You're learning wisdom. You're gaining
experience, and that will only cause the
light to grow, okay?
So, even though, going back to the story
of Eve and my dog, even though I'm
hurting myself, okay?
I am using my tremendous imagination in
order to come up with this plan in order
to redeem my daughter.
And because of this imagination,
I'm developing wisdom, and this light in
me grows stronger.
All right? So, that's the purpose of
life. The purpose of life is to
celebrate God by
celebrating
God in you, by loving someone else so
wholeheartedly that your imagination,
your wisdom grows and grows so that your
soul becomes eternal. When it becomes
eternal, it will always be resurrected
in the world.
And your soul will remember the love
inside you and it will continue to grow
and grow.
Okay? This is why God created us because
if God if you're a perfect, okay? If
you're a perfect, you are incapable of
imagination by definition. Right?
Because you make you make no mistakes.
Because we are we are the dual nature,
we are both body and soul,
we can make mistakes. We can err.
And in this process, we develop we
develop experience and wisdom, which
allows us to love and have imagination.
And have wisdom. Right?
All right.
So,
let me use an everyday example that
you've experienced in order to
illustrate this point. Let's think of
think about two teachers. A teacher who
loves his or her students and a teacher
who does not love his or her students,
okay? What's the difference? All right.
So, there are two major differences.
The teacher who loves students always
asking himself or herself, are my
students learning in my class? Are they
growing as people?
Whereas another teacher might be like,
are my students getting good grades?
All he or she cares about are test
scores, right? That's the first major
difference.
The first teacher who loves you cares
about what what is happening inside you.
What? The The teacher who doesn't love
you only cares about pleasing parents.
Okay?
Second difference is this.
The teacher who loves you are asking,
are my students working hard?
Okay? Because only by working hard can
you learn.
The second teacher is asking students,
do students like me, okay? This teacher
wants you to write a good good
evaluation at the end of semester, okay?
Right? And then
if you write a good
uh evaluation, the teacher might get a
raise or some reward, right?
And then the last difference, and this
is the most important difference, is
this: A good teacher who loves you is
always asking, "Am I growing personally
and professionally? Am I growing as a
person?"
All right?
Because if you're growing, then I'm
growing. And if I'm growing, then you're
growing.
That's the power of love. Okay? When you
love others, you're actually loving
yourself.
And that's how God designed it.
But if you're a teacher who does not
love, then you're always asking, "How
much money am I making?" That's how you
measure your success in life. Am I
making a lot of money? If If I'm making
millions of dollars a year, then that
means I'm the I'm the best teacher in
China, okay? But a really good teacher
who's capable of love, who loves
teaching and who loves his or her
students, is always asking, "Am I
growing?" Because if I'm growing, then I
know my students are growing.
Okay?
So that's So that's what Dante is saying
here about love.
Meaning that we have intuition
with a power to know truth for ourselves
because God made us made us this way.
Okay.
So, um, something I want you to remember
from this class is
the Italian Renaissance was really
just another It's It's reimagining the
Greek civilization, okay? And as And
these are the two major periods of
tremendous creativity in Western Europe.
All right? So, let's look at the
similarities to understand how
creativity happens in civilization.
Okay? So, the first similarity is
um, classical Greece had open corporate
competition, okay? So, ideas could flow
freely.
That's the first major similarity.
Second major similarity is
in classical Greece, the transition from
Linear B, which is very complicated
um ideographic language, to the
alphabet, okay? The alphabet just
transcribes the written the spoken word
into the written word. This allows for
massive literacy and the transfusion of
knowledge in Greece. And the idea here
is, if you are truly to to be a creative
society, you must be egalitarian. You
must allow anyone
to learn, everyone to express his or her
um ideas, which is what the Renaissance
did, okay?
Um the Italian Renaissance was supported
by the fact that the transition from
Latin to the vernacular, the spoken
language. It was Dante who allowed the
transition to happen, okay? Dante
purposely chose not to write in Latin,
even though Latin was the official
language of the intellectual class in
Europe at this time. He purposely chose
to write in Tuscan, which is the local
language. And because he did that, he
made Tuscan, first of all, the official
language of Italy. They still speak it
today. But it also makes the Divine
Comedy accessible to common people,
which was the intention, okay?
And the third similarity, and this is
the most important, is
the perfect storm of factors don't
really matter
unless you have a great poet, a great
thinker, a great intellectual to create
the spark to ignite your civilization,
okay? So, in Greece, they had Homer. And
we we today we can think of Homer as the
father of civilization.
In In the Italian Renaissance, you had
Dante. You can think of him as the
father of modernity. The values that he
creates,
the values that he expresses in the
Divine Comedy, will become the basis
for modernity, especially the idea of
individuality, of humanism, right?
What's an individual? An individual is
someone who celebrates himself and
pursues his or her
curiosity to explore the world and in
this process create goodness in the
world to create truth and beauty. This
is the idea that will underpin the
Renaissance and which still underpins
Western modernity
uh
today.
Okay?
So, that is my argument to you. Okay?
Great. So,
um the ultimate message
the ultimate secret of the universe that
I want you to remember, okay? And both
Homer and Dante expressed this in their
poetry is this.
Love is the unifying force of the
universe, okay?
Love is God. God is love. It's what
unites everyone. Okay? By loving someone
else, you can become that person. And
that person that person can become you.
And the imagination is the animating
force.
Okay? What gives life to the world is
not God, but our imagination.
By imagining the world, the world
becomes alive. So, the greater
imagination, the more alive our
imagination becomes. And this idea is
most visually expressed in the painting
The Creation of Adam by Michelangelo.
Okay?
This is Michelangelo
um the Creation of Adam.
And so, this goes back to the story of
how God created Adam.
Uh God created um Adam out of dust and
he breathed
the essence of life into Adam, okay?
Now, there are two ways
of looking at this painting, okay? The
two ways of understanding the title The
Creation of Adam. You can first
understand it in the typical way, which
is that God created Adam and that they
are equals, okay? You can see that these
two worlds, the Adam and God, they're
almost equal. Okay? We are equal to God.
But then you can change perspective and
you can say The Creation of Adam really
means
God is Adam's creation.
God is what we created from our
imagination. All right? Now, you can see
God
um
is surrounded by his angels. Okay? But,
you take them away, and what do you have
behind them?
Guys, this is a picture of the human
brain.
Right? Do you see this?
Okay, this is a stem, okay? And this is
the
human brain. Okay? You take them away,
and hidden behind is the human brain.
Right? Which means what? Which means
that God is an emanation from our
imagination.
Okay?
Not the true God. The true God is
like light itself, right? Love itself,
okay? But, this God has given us the
capacity to imagine, so we've imagined
another God to
um
take place of the real God. Okay? Do you
understand? So, the real God is the
human imagination.
The human brain, the human mind.
That's what gives life to the universe,
okay? So, this, if you think about it,
it is a radical revolution
in
human intellectual history.
Okay, do you know where this painting
is?
This painting
is on the top of something called the
Sistine Chapel in the Vatican.
It's at the very heart of the Catholic
Church.
So, what Donne has been able to do is
destroy an empire
peacefully, for the power of poetry,
through subtlety, for the power of love.
Donne was able to influence
Michelangelo, who was able to take his
ideas, and then plant his ideas within
the very heart of the Catholic Church,
and thus reinvent the Catholic Church.
That is the power of love. That is the
power of the imagination.
Right?
Great.
Okay, any questions?
Okay. So, think of some questions. Um
next class, we will do the Protestant
Reformation, okay?